واصطدميه تتحكم بمصيرهم يحاول لبنانيون
جاهدين مواجهه الازمات الاقتصاديه
وارتدادات الانسداد السياسي والشهور
الرئاسي اما الشباب فيجدون انفسهم في صراع
بين واقع مرير يعيشونه واحلى من تراودهم
بمستقبل افضل ثمن
كل واحد على اي بلد
نشوفك
الازمات التي يشهدها لبنان
في الاسواق الصوره ليست افضل حالا
هنا يشتري اللبنانيون ما تيسر فغالبيت هذه
المنتجات باتت خارجه امكاناتهم ارتفاع
اسعارها
يفرشها علينا بقى بكل شيء بكل شيء
لكن السلطات واجهتها بخطوات موضعيه قصيره
عن وقف الانهيار مع دخول الانهيار
الاقتصادي عامه الرابع يعاني اكثر من نصف
قاتل لبنان من انعدام الامن الغذائي ويرون
ان السلطات المتقاعسه عن تنفيذ الاصلاحات
واعاده هيكله القطاع المصرفي وابرام
الاتفاق النهائي مع صندوق النقد توا
السياسي لانسداد السيد الموقف والشعور في
سوده الرئاسه يكاد يصيب السلطتين
التنفيذيه والتشريعيه بشلل يترافق مع
انهيار الاقتصاديا غير مسبوق عمليا
السلطه التشريعيه وهذا الشيء عم بيصير
بلحظه البلد احواش ما يكون الى السلطتين
في ظل تازهم اقتصادي اجتماعي مالي لازم
لبناني ياخذ قرارات سريعه وان لا يكون
مترددان في مواجهات ال- اقلوا الاشياء
اللي طالبها النقد الدولي
والازمات وفي لبنان وتتشعب ميادينها اما
السلطات المعنيه فتبدو عجزه عن اشتراء
حلول تستجيب لحاجات لبنانيين ومطالبهم
بالاصلاح وبناء الدوله كارلوس خدر الجزيره
بيروت